Hey Wisecrack, Jared again.
Today, we’re returning to the underwater
city of Rapture to talk about one of the most
widely discussed video game franchises in
recent memory: BioShock.
Of course, longtime viewers will remember
that we covered the philosophy of BioShock
1 and BioShock: Infinite in the first ever
Wisecrack Edition over four years ago!
But you guys were pretty quick to point out
that we made a purposeful but glaring omission
in that video.
So, today, we’re finally going to go back
and address the often forgotten, frequently
maligned middle child of the BioShock franchise,
BioShock 2.
At the time of its release, BioShock 2 was
noted for lacking the involvement of the series
creator Ken Levine.
In a 2010 interview, Levine said that he and
his team at Irrational Games passed on developing
the sequel because they wanted to avoid repeating
themselves.
“We’re always trying to challenge ourselves,”
“We felt we had said what we wanted to say
about Rapture, about those kinds of environments
and that kind of feel.”
Despite this intimation from Levine that BioShock
2 is a bit of a rehash of the original, there
is still a contingent of fans out there who
remain steadfast in their belief that it is
a great game, praising it for its improved
mechanics and the spin it puts on the themes
of Bioshock 1.
So, now that we’ve had nearly a decade of
distance from this potentially disappointing
sequel, let’s revisit BioShock 2 and evaluate
whether it was as successful as some people
seem to think, whether it reached the same
intellectual heights as the franchise’s
first installment, whether it’s deep or
dumb.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Edition on Bioshock
2.
And, as always, spoilers ahead.
Alright first things first, let’s do a little
recap.
In BioShock 2, you play as Delta, a prototype
of a Big Daddy living in Andrew Ryan’s underwater
utopia of Rapture.
Like all Big Daddies, you were tasked with
protecting a Little Sister, and in the case
of Delta, that Little Sister’s name was
Eleanor.
In the game’s prologue, Eleanor is snatched
away from you by the main antagonist, Dr.
Sofia Lamb, who then uses mind control to
force you to commit suicide.
Ten years later, you emerge from a Vita-Chamber
having been miraculously resurrected.
You are then led through the crumbling city
of Rapture with the aid of Eleanor’s telepathic
messages and a little help from some unlikely
allies.
Your mission is to find Eleanor and save her
from the sinisterly soft-spoken Sofia Lamb,
who, by the way, is Eleanor’s mother.
Pretty soon, you learn that Dr. Lamb was once
a celebrated psychologist in the heyday of
Rapture, but, after Andrew Ryan’s death
in the first BioShock, she transformed Ryan’s
failed objectivist utopia into a utilitarian
collectivist hellscape.
Lamb has manipulated the poorest most disenfranchised
citizens of Rapture through propaganda and
plasmid addiction to be fiercely loyal to
her and the rest of the “Rapture Family.”
What’s more, the Family deifies Eleanor
as the “first true utopian” because Lamb
has been pumping her full of ADAM in an attempt
to create a completely selfless, completely
altruistic being.
Lamb’s followers paper the walls of the
city with iconography representing her and
Eleanor that states, “We will be reborn.
She is our savior.”
As you make your way to Lamb’s hideout,
you encounter her various allies who you can
choose to kill or spare depending on how generous
you’re feeling or how obnoxious their repeated
dialogue is.
There’s also a new class of enemies called
Big Sisters, which are more spritely, acrobatic
versions of the Big Daddies that haunt Rapture’s
halls.
There is still the same Little Sisters mechanic
from the first game, which forces you to choose
between saving the yellow-eyed innocents or
zapping them for their precious ADAM.
As always, the choices you make determine
what kind of ending you get, either good,
bad, or neutral.
That’s pretty much it.
You explore the city blasting splicers, in
an attempt to rescue your surrogate daughter
from the clutches of her evil mother.
But, BioShock has never been just a first-person
shooter.
The games set themselves apart from others
in the genre with their rich world-building,
expertly-paced storytelling, and use of philosophical
texts to explore deeper themes.
But, just how deep can BioShock 2 get when
it’s starting at the bottom of the ocean?
Part 1: The Triumphant Lamb We Worship
In its depictions of the cultish Rapture Family
and their fanatical worship of Sofia and Eleanor
Lamb, BioShock 2 offers some pretty decent
commentary on the dangers of religious zealotry.
Whereas the first game poked holes in Ayn
Rand’s objectivism by showing the natural
conclusion of a utopia built on radical self-interest,
BioShock 2 flips the script by presenting
a criticism of blind, selfless devotion to
a higher cause.
While these two ideologies may seem at odds
with one another, especially given that atheism
is a central tenet of objectivism, the game
takes great pains to show that they have more
in common than one might think.
NARRATOR
The people of Rapture, lost and leaderless
following the Civil War between Ryan and Fontaine
and the death of both characters at the end
of BioShock 1, are seduced by Lamb’s philosophy
and begin joining the Rapture Family in droves.
A skilled psychologist, Lamb plays into their
anger at the system that failed them and promises
them something greater through these new beliefs.
These people, many of whom struggled to feed
themselves in Ryan’s utopia, are now willing
to throw their lives away at Lamb’s word.
We’ve seen this kind of zealotry throughout
history, both religiously and politically,
as people have thrown away their lives or
political freedoms in the name of a higher
cause.
Lamb’s targeting of the most poverty-stricken
members of the population is more of a direct
allusion to early Chritianity, which flourished
in the Roman Empire because of church leaders’
willingness to preach to and incorporate the
lowest members of society.
The fact that the word “lamb” is often
used to refer to Jesus Christ is no more an
accident than Andrew Ryan’s name being a
clumsy anagram of Ayn Rand.
This mirroring of religious methodology is
plainly obvious in the character Father Simon
Wales.
Once a downtrodden citizen of Rapture’s
poorest neighborhood, Wales is energized by
Lamb’s philosophy and converts it into simple
religious doctrine that even the most ADAM-corrupted
splicer can understand.
The senseless death of Wales and his many
followers underscores the danger posed by
a complete surrender of the self.
This is the antithesis of the first game’s
message, which focused on the danger of complete
and total self-interest.
BioShock 2’s argument appears to be that
things on the flipside can be just as bad,
much like how the tear-universe sequence in
BioShock: Infinite depicts the populist Vox
Populi freedom fighters ruling over Columbia
with the same authoritarian violence as Comstock.
It’s a cynical take to say the least, but
it’s at least coherent, and a good reminder
to occasionally criticize your own actions
instead of giving yourself over to blind faith.
For that reason, we’re going to give this
aspect of the game a “deep.”
Ok, so BioShock 2 does a nice job criticizing
over-zealous devotion to Lamb’s philosophy.
But, what exactly is her philosophy?
Part 2: When the Greater Good Goes Bad
In the same way that Andrew Ryan was a physical
embodiment of Ayn Rand’s objectivist philosophy,
Sofia Lamb is an amalgamation of a number
of different utilitarian thinkers, most notably
John Stuart Mill.
Mill was a British philosopher born in 1806
who was seen by many as the direct successor
to Jeremy Bentham, the father of utilitarian
ethics.
In his book, aptly titled Utilitarianism,
Mill provides a summary explanation and defense
of his philosophy founded on the “greatest
happiness principle” which states that “actions
are right in proportion as they tend to promote
happiness, wrong as they tend to produce the
reverse of happiness.”
In other words, what is good is what creates
the most happiness for the most people.
This brand of morality is under the umbrella
of consequentialist ethics, meaning that,
when it comes to determining the morality
of an action, the ends justify the means.
Rand’s version of rational egoism is also
a consequentialist theory.
But where Rand believes each person should
act in their own self-interest for their own
happiness, utilitarians favor lessening focus
on the self and prioritizing the happiness
of everyone instead.
This line of thinking would certainly appeal
to someone like Sofia Lamb, who has convinced
herself that turning Eleanor into an ego-less
ADAM repository would be the ultimate dissolution
of the self and usher in a new utopia.
And like any good consequentialist, she seems
hellbent on accomplishing this goal by any
means necessary.
All her actions throughout the game— the
confinement of Eleanor, the kidnapping of
young girls to make into Little Sisters, the
careless manipulation of Splicers —are all
done in the name of a future greater good.
Still, it’s pretty hard to argue that Lamb’s
actions are promoting happiness or hindering
suffering across the board.
Throughout your entire stay in the city of
Rapture, the only person who seems to be having
a good time is that damn clown.
And if Lamb is really meant to be a student
of Mill’s philosophy, she maybe should have
paid a little closer attention to the text.
In his essay On Liberty, Mill very clearly
states that “The sole end for which mankind
are warranted, individually or collectively,
in interfering with the liberty of action
of any of their number, is self-protection.
That the only purpose for which power can
be rightfully exercised over any member of
a civilized community, against his will, is
to prevent harm to others.
Basically, the ends don’t justify the means
if it requires hurting people.
Practically the entire action of the game
is set around members of Lamb’s collective
attempting to do harm to Delta through a series
of surprise attacks.
The argument could be made that, by attempting
to free Eleanor, Delta is doing harm to the
Rapture Family and they’re only acting in
self-defense.
But that argument is about as airtight as
Dionysus Park.
Ultimately, Lamb talks a big game about her
utilitarian, collectivist beliefs but falls
well short of actually being a utilitarian.
Her book Unity and Metamorphosis, excerpts
of which are heard throughout the game, asserts
the evolution of the human race is leading
to a death of the self, a complete loss of
ego, and, subsequently, the end of tyranny.
But, in practice, Lamb is acting like a selfish
tyrant.
She performs dangerous experiments on her
own daughter.
She turns young girls and men into Little
Sisters and Big Daddies against their will.
She kills anybody who attempts to leave Rapture.
All so she can be proven right in her beliefs
and create some hypothesized, ADAM-fueled
God.
She would consider this to be the ultimate
death of the self, but for anyone besides
her, there doesn’t seem to be much utility
in it.
In the character of Dr. Sofia Lamb, BioShock
2 attempted to create a philosophical villain
that believed in everything Andrew Ryan despised
and still managed to be evil.
Unfortunately, it’s difficult to make a
truly selfless, charitable, collectivist perform
acts of villainy without seeming incoherent.
If their philosophy is about selflessness,
but they’re on some egotistical power trip,
you can see how that might criticize the power
trip more than the philosophy itself.
So, we’re going to have to give this section
a “dumb.”
However, if you’re going to argue that the
game is less criticizing the actual philosophy
like in Bioshock 1, and more criticizing how
these philosophies are poorly implemented
by tyrants, we could see how one might call
it deep.
Unfortunately for Sofia Lamb, the inconsistency
between her beliefs and actions is only one
of her problems.
The other, is where she lives.
Part 3: Haven’t We Been Here Before?
By placing the events of BioShock 2 in the
same location as BioShock 1, the philosophy
and actions of people like Sofia Lamb are
immediately placed in the context of Ryan’s
world.
You may be playing as a different character,
but the story is a continuation of the first
game in every sense of the word.
So much so that it’s difficult to avoid
picking up audio diaries from familiar old
characters filling in unnecessary plot points.
The game is riddled with superfluous winks
and nods to stuff from Bioshock 1, making
this feel more like DLC than a sequel.
And because of this, the villains of BioShock
2 are never given a chance to breathe.
In the first BioShock, we’re given glimpses
of Ryan’s utopia at its peak.
We’re shown the potential of his lofty dream,
which is what makes the crumbly reality of
it hit that much harder.
The criticism of objectivism is more biting
because we see the fallout from these beliefs.
In BioShock 2, the new utopia never gets off
the ground because things have already gone
to hell.
Lamb and her followers are attempting to rise
from the ashes but they can’t shake off
Ryan’s ghost.
Lamb presented her philosophy as an alternative
to Ryan’s, but her utilitarianism or anarcho-collectivism
or whatever you want to call it never manifested
in the way that Ryan’s magical city at the
bottom of the ocean did.
And, in the end, the result was the same anyway.
In-fighting, destruction, death, and a one-way
trip in a bathysphere to the surface.
It’s hard to effectively poke holes in a
new ideology when the player is still inhabiting
a world ruined by the previous one, and when
the presence of said ideology is only in the
antagonist’s words, not in her actions.
NARRATOR
BioShock as a franchise is about how the lofty
ambitions of men are doomed to fail because
of inherent personal flaws.
But in BioShock 2, those lofty ambitions amount
to some vague talk about how a young woman
is going to be turned into a utopia.
So, you’re left trudging through a city
you’ve already trudged through, all for
the sake of saving your daughter who isn’t
even really your daughter.
NARRATOR
Oddly enough, that’s also one of the best
things you can say about BioShock 2.
It’s trying to tell a personal, emotional
story.
A story about a Big Daddy and a Little Sister.
A story that’s either about redemption or
loss of innocence depending on how you play.
For some people that’s enough, and for that
reason, we’ll settle on giving BioShock
2 a rating of “kinda deep.”
Sure, the criticism of philosophical ideologies
is pretty toothless, but it has some interesting
things to say about the inherent value of
the self and the power of caring about someone
rather than the vague notion of everyone.
But what do you guys think?
Is Bioshock 2 a fitting sequel to one of the
most revered games of all time?
Let us know what you think in the comments.
Thanks to all our patrons who support the
channel and our podcasts.
Don’t forget to hit that subscribe button